>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington DC.
>> Levon Avdoyan: You know, in my
nearly 40 years here at the Library
of Congress, my favorite
words have become the last 21,
welcome to the Vardanants
Day Arminian Lecture.
This time the 21st lecture.
I see many familiar faces.
Some of whom I will acknowledge
a little later, in the beginning.
But I see one who has been here
almost every year, not here.
And I'd like to call the attention
to the fact that my sister,
who has been extremely
supportive, Lynn Young,
was caught in the floods of Houston.
Went through two shelters.
And is at least safe and sound
with her daughter now in Denver.
She's one of the lucky ones.
So, I would personally like
to dedicate this event,
the 21st Vardanants Lecture
to all those suffering
from this horrendous hurricane.
Before I go any further, I
would like to introduce a friend
and colleague and a great
supporter of the Armenian Programs
and Collections at the Library
of Congress, Dr. Mary-Jane Deeb,
Chief of the African and
Middle Eastern Division.
[ Applause ]
>> Mary-Jane Deeb: Thank you.
Thank you, Levon.
And good afternoon everyone.
And welcome to the Library of
Congress and to the African
and Middle Eastern Division.
Thank you, Ambassador Hovhannissian.
And thank you all for being here to
celebrate with us Vardanants Day.
The 21st such celebration in one
of the longest running series
of programs in the
Library's history.
Many of you, as was mentioned,
have attended these programs
over the years, organized
by Dr. Levon Avdoyan.
The one and only Armenian
specialist at the Library.
Never before him had there
been an Armenian specialist.
But thanks to a generous grant
from Mrs. Margorie Dadian, in 1991,
the Library established a position
for an Armenian specialist.
And provided funds to build a
collection of Armenian books,
serials, manuscripts, newspapers,
as well as expand the
collections in other formats.
Such as, maps, photographs,
prints, films and much more.
The fund, which exists to
promote Armenian collections,
has been used very wisely by Levon.
In the past two decades, he
has built this collection
by increasing his items seven-fold.
From an estimated six
or seven items in 1991,
to around 47,000 items today.
He also used the funds to
create the first ever exhibit
on the Armenian book in 2012,
entitled "To Know Wisdom
and Instruction, the
Armenian Literary Tradition
at the Library of Congress."
It was accompanied by an illustrated
catalogue, a book really,
of the same title, on the Armenian
collections at the Library.
The book, which Dr. Avdoyan
wrote, originally in English,
was later translated into Armenian.
And eventually, both versions
were published online.
Dr. Avdoyan has not only focused on
developing the Armenian collection
and having it preserved and
made accessible to readers.
But has also organized numerous
programs around that collection.
The best known as undoubtedly been
the long running annual Vardanants
Day Series.
Its goal is to present topics on
all aspects of Armenian history,
culture, politics and society.
In that, he has succeeded
beautifully.
And you can go to our webpage
and find the webcast of each
of the previous 20 programs.
And today, once again, to
celebrate Vardanants Day,
Levon has invited an
award-winning writer,
whose work has received the
highest level of recognition.
And who is participating in the
National Book Festival tomorrow.
Although Chris Bohjalian is the
New York Times best seller author
of 19 novels, he is
here today to talk
about another aspect
of his life and work.
I will not say anymore, as
I know that Levon will want
to introduce him more fully.
So, now, Levon.
Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan: If you listen
to Mary-Jane's introduction,
you would think that this is
a one man show, but it isn't.
I'm going to go through
that a little later.
But we've been blessed with
many partners in the endeavor.
And I pointed out that
the Armenian collections
and the Vardanants Lecture,
have grown up the last 25 years,
with the Republic of Armenia.
And one of those partners has always
been the Embassy of the Republic
or Armenia to the United States.
I would like to introduce
to you the present holder
of the Ambassadorship there.
Who has one won my praise
and friendship for being one
of the most energetic I have known.
And so, please join me in
welcoming his Excellency Ambassador
Grigor Hovhannissian.
[ Applause ]
>> Ambassador Grigor Hovhannissian:
Thank you very much Levon.
That was a very generous
introduction.
I'd like to reciprocate.
Knowing you, having you in
Washington is a blessing
for me personally and for the
Republic for the Armenian culture.
I thank you for the work
you do all these years.
And I can't stress it
enough how appreciative
and grateful we are
for the work you do.
And we cherish this
institution and cooperation
with the Library of Congress.
That has become one of
the true cultural bridges
between Armenia and
the United States.
A landmark event of which the
Vardanants Day invariably makes
intellectual contributions
to the Armenian culture,
to the civilization.
Not to mention the massive impact
it makes on disseminating knowledge
about our country and
Armenian civilization.
I thank you very much Mrs. Deebs
dear compatriots, Ambassador Evans,
great friend of Armenians
for being here today.
Today marks the beginning of --
actually, in a way it's
a new year, you know.
Because people are
back from vacation.
September marks a beginning
to hard work for many of us.
There's lots of challenges
ahead of us.
You know, there's changes
in Armenia.
There's changes in
the United States.
But institutions like
the Library of Congress,
the Cultural Institutions
activities ongoing,
help us maintain the overall, you
know, the level of friendship.
And commitment of both
countries, Armenia
and the United States
have towards each other.
I thank you all for all you do.
And I'm very pleased that I'll be
witnessing an extraordinary lecture
by a celebrity.
A person who we already,
in the Armenian world,
called varpet, master.
Only a few of our big
writers, big artists,
you know, deserve that title.
He's -- he won that right already.
And I'm very happy I'll be -- these
lectures happening on my watch.
And I thank you, Levon,
for putting this together.
And as a token of our appreciation,
last year I promised I will
never be coming empty handed.
And today I brought the 47,000
first book to your collection.
[ Laughter and Applause ]
Very much reminiscent
of the topic, you know,
is the DNA Western Armenia
or Eastern Anatolia.
An incredibly rich volume that
provides the before and after look
at the cultural patrimony
of the Armenian civilization
of what we commonly
call Western Armenia.
Thank you very much.
>> Thank you.
[ Applause ]
>> Levon Avdoyan: You see,
his Excellency doesn't know
that I invite him because he always
brings books, so [brief laughter].
Now, I'd like to get as rapidly as
possible to the meat of the lecture.
But there are people I
do need to acknowledge.
His Excellency pointed out that
John Evans, former Ambassador
for the United States to Armenia,
is yet again with us in support.
Friendly faces and colleagues.
We have Dr. Paul Krigo, [assumed
spelling] who was my partner
and acquisitions in cataloging
of Armenian materials.
We have Tomoro Ohanian
[assumed spelling]
and Jasmine Han [assumed
spelling] of Conservation,
who have done so much to
actually preserve our materials.
And it's really, we have
done a marvelous job here.
We have members of the community.
We have members from
Prints and Photographs.
We have a lot of friends
here to listen to you, Chris.
But about Chris.
I have put a biography
of facts in the program.
I don't want to go
through his numerous awards
and what he has accomplished.
What I want to say, in a few words,
is that when I started graduate work
at Columbia in 1968, my
colleagues, my fellow Armenians,
were amused when I
said I have one index
to whether a good --
a book is good or not.
And I look in the index and if
it has Armenia in it, it's good.
And if it doesn't have
Armenia in it, it doesn't.
Many years ago, an Armenian
friend of mine said, well,
what do you think of
Chris Bohjalian's novels?
And I said, well, I don't know.
I haven't read one.
And I got "Secrets of Eden" out.
And I didn't find Armenia in it.
But I loved it.
It was a quintessential
American novel.
Excellent storytelling,
wonderful pros.
A sense to it that
really intrigued me,
that lead me to read a
few others at that time.
And then, five years ago,
something miraculous happened
to all of us in the community.
And that is Chris authored a book
called "The Sandcastle Girls."
The very personal account,
the very hard account
to read for Armenian Americans.
But a wonderful account
of the Armenian genocide.
And I, at that point, met Chris
for the first time and
I liked what I saw.
I liked what I saw and felt
very friendly toward Chris.
To the point that I, last year,
asked an embarrassing question.
Which was, Chris, tell me, will
you ever write a humorous novel?
To which and I have this e-mailed
response, "Oh, heavens no."
"All my books are about
dread" [brief laughter].
They may be about dread, but
they are all exquisitely written.
They are all well thought out.
I've read several since,
"The Guest Room," this year,
which I urge you to read.
Now, I don't know if I can say
that or not, but I am saying that.
And I understand next March,
"The Flight Attendant,"
his 20th novel will appear.
Those of you who know me, know
that I am extremely interested
in the question of identity.
And so, when I thought of
identity in literature,
there was only one name that I
could think of to address you.
So, I asked Chris if he would talk
about the possible impact influence
of ethnic identity on
literary creativity.
He readily accepted.
And so, ladies and
gentlemen, I ask you to join me
in welcoming Chris Bohjalian, as he
talks about "Echoes of Anatolia."
An Armenian American novelist
discovers his literary DNA
at midlife.
[ Applause ]
>> Chris Bohjalian: Thank you,
Levon, for that introduction.
[ Speaking in Foreign Language ]
It is a pleasure.
It is an honor.
It is a privilege to join
you on this the 21st lecture.
Ambassador Hovhannissian,
thank you for being here.
Ambassador Evans, thank
you for being here.
I thank all of you for joining me
this Friday of Labor Day weekend.
It is a particular pleasure
to be with all of you here
at the Library of Congress.
Because the last time I was
here, was indeed five years ago,
for Levon's remarkable
curated exhibition,
"To Know Wisdom and Instruction."
It was profoundly meaningful to
see 500 years of Armenian printing.
Five hundred years
of Armenian culture
in this magnificent building
in our nations capitol.
I know Levon as a friend.
But I know he is also an
enormous gift to the Library
of Congress, to Armenian Americans.
And to Armenians around the world,
for his magisterial work curating
a collection to remind people
of our long venerated
magnificent history.
Levon, thank you for
all that you do.
It is a particular pleasure
to be with all of you today
because I'm not on a book tour.
Make no mistake, I like book tours.
It wasn't all that long
ago that my sold briskly.
But only among people
with my last name.
I try never to lose
sight of that fact.
Most people presume, however,
that book tours are
unbelievable glamourous.
You jet around the country and
you hang with Oprah and Katy
and Terry Gross and sell
whole pallets of books.
But the reality of most book
tours is this, by day 14,
you will have been
on 17 regional jets.
And you will have been reduced
to wearing a strange man's
underwear [brief laughter].
I wish I could say
I'm making that up.
I am not. It really
happened to me on the
"Secrets of Eden's" book tour.
You see, what happens on a book
tour is that the publisher wants
to get you to as many cities as
possible, as quickly as possible.
So, you spend one night
in every city.
Monday is Boston.
Tuesday is New York.
Wednesday is Washington.
Thursday is L.A. And you
do this for three weeks.
One night, one city, one hotel.
If you're a novelist, there's
nothing in the world you want more
than two nights in a row in the
same city, in the same hotel
for one reason and one
reason only, laundry.
You need that second full night
to get your laundry taken care of.
So, on the "Secrets of Eden"
book tour, I get to Minneapolis,
Saint Paul on Friday
afternoon at 4:00.
And I see I'm not checking
out until Sunday morning.
And so, happier than
I've been in two weeks.
I send out a MINI Cooper
sized pile of laundry.
I do my Friday night event.
I have two appearances on Saturday.
I get back to my hotel Saturday
night and there on the bed,
under plastic, are all of my
shirts, which have been dry-cleaned.
And a box with my laundry,
which is book tour euphemism
for my underwear.
Since I'm checking
out Sunday morning,
I open my suitcase on the floor.
And I open the box on the bed,
planning to move my underwear
in one neat and tidy
brick, into the suitcase.
So, I open the box and in there
are 14 pairs of underwear,
not mine [brief laughter].
Not a man's [brief laughter].
They belonged to a
very petite woman.
Now, I've done this long enough
to know that rule number one
of a book tour is that you
never give the hotel all
of your underwear.
I still have three pairs.
We are not in crisis mode.
So, Sunday morning, the
hotel laundry is closed.
And I am checking out.
So, I give these 14 pairs of
women's underwear to the bellman.
And I said, here is the
hotel where I'm going
to be Tuesday in Orlando, Florida.
And if you could send
my underwear there
by Federal Express, I'd be grateful.
And we both looked at
each other like, yeah,
that's going to happen
[brief laughter].
So, then I check out.
And whenever you're on a book tour,
your publisher gives you an escort.
Not that kind.
These are the lovely women and
men who know where the library is,
the bookstore is, the radio,
TV stations are, in every city.
And they get you to
and from the airport.
And in Minnesota, it's a
wonderful guy named Tim.
So, I get in the car with Tim
and I said, Tim, by any miracle,
is there a store between here and
the airport that's open right now,
where I can get some new underwear?
And he said two things to me
that were kind of interesting.
The first thing he said
was, wow, you're, like,
the third author I've had this
month who needs new underwear.
And he said there's a Macy's,
but you'll have to be quick.
So, we go to the Macy's.
I go to men's department.
I get my underwear.
It's in a red Macy's bag.
And we go to the airport.
And no one flies through
airport security as quickly
as a novelist on a book tour.
I throw the shoes, the laptop, the
cellphone and my red Macy's bag
of underwear in the conveyor belt.
And I fly through the
metal detector.
So, now, I'm boarding regional
jet number 18 from Milwaukee.
And as I am boarding, I realize I
no longer have my red Macy's bag
of underwear.
How do I know this?
I hear the following over
the airport loud speakers.
Would the gentlemen
who left his underwear,
please return to security
[brief laughter].
Bedlam at the gate.
Oh, my gosh, they really
are strip searching us now!
[brief laughter].
I couldn't go back for it.
So, I flew into Milwaukee and
had a lovely event in Milwaukee.
I had a terrific even
Monday in Madison.
So, Tuesday, I fly
onto Orlando, Florida.
As I'm checking into my hotel
room on Tuesday afternoon,
the woman behind the
counter says, Mr. Bohjalian,
we have a Federal Express
box for you.
And I look at it and it is
from the hotel in Minneapolis.
I cradle it against my chest,
as if it is Christmas morning.
I go to my hotel room
and I open it up.
And sure enough, in there are
14 pairs of underwear, not mine!
[brief laughter].
But they were a man's and they
were boxers and they were clean.
And so, I did the last week of
the "Secrets of Eden" book tour
in a strange man's underwear.
And I was grateful.
You didn't know this was going to be
such an intellectually
rigorous presentation.
Underwear, that brings us to
my work, to our work together,
indeed, "Echoes of Anatolia."
How an Armenian American novelist
rediscovered his literary DNA
at midlife.
For most of my career as a
novelist, I've not been known
as an Armenian American writer.
I've been known as an American
Novelist, most of whose books,
not all, but most were
set in New England.
And most of those books were
about thorny social issues
and moral conundrums.
Books such as 1997's "Midwives."
About a Vermont midwife
on trial for manslaughter,
after a cataclysmic home birth.
Books such as "Trans-Sister
Radio," in the year 2000.
A novel of a love affair
between a woman
and a man who's transitioning
to become a woman.
And the way their transgender love
story rocks their Vermont community.
And by rocks, I don't mean
in a good Taylor Swift,
Rolling Stones sort of way.
But rocks, as in the
tectonic plates are shifting.
And all that we understand
about gender is shifting.
Or "The Double Bind," in 2007.
The story of a Vermont social worker
who believes that she has found,
among her clients, the bastard son
of Jay Gatsby and Daisy
Fay Buchanan.
All of that changed in 2012,
when I published my novel,
"The Sandcastle Girls."
A love story between
an American woman
and an Armenian man,
in Aleppo, in 1915.
Yes, that Aleppo that has broken all
of our hearts the last five years.
In some ways, however,
though I started writing
"The Sandcastle Girls," was
I was in my late forties.
It is a book that had been
gestating inside me my entire life.
To understand the origins of "The
Sandcastle Girls," means going back
in time, all the way to the
last decade of the 19th century.
Come with me to the
oldest family photograph
and the Bohjalian family archives.
The Ottoman City of Kayseri,
it is Southeast of Ankara.
This photograph was
taken, we believe, in 1894.
It's my great grandfather
and his family.
The patriarch of the family,
that's Nazaret Bedros Bohjalian.
When I was growing up in the suburbs
of New York City in the 1960's
and early 1970's, whenever we
would discuss this photograph,
I would always be told
that Nazaret was a tailor.
That's what he did.
He was a tailor.
At the very end of
this presentation,
we will come back to Nazaret.
But I want to spend a moment now
on the little boy on his lap.
That's my grandfather,
Levon Nazareth.
Flash forward 35 or so
years to New York City,
another family photograph.
Levon is now grown up.
He's again, seated.
This is a photograph of my
father and my grandparents.
And it is my favorite
photograph I have of my father.
I love this picture of
him as a little boy.
The short pants.
The big wide ears.
The necktie that falls three
inches above his navel.
Standing behind him, is
grandmother, Haigouhi Sherinian.
Elegant grey-black dress.
White collar.
The corsage the size of a softball.
In my grandmother, I can see
echoes of my beautiful daughter,
Grace Experience, who
is with us today.
And sitting beside them, Levon.
He's wearing a suit.
In my memories, my grandfather
is always wearing a suit.
I once asked his daughter,
my aunt Rose Mary.
I said aunt Rose Mary,
when you were growing up,
was your father always
wearing a suit?
And she laughed and laughed and
said, no, Chris, of course not.
I remember one day when he
was cleaning the oil burner,
he took off his jacket
[brief laughter].
Those were my grandparents.
Levon and Haigouhi, were
survivors of the Armenian genocide.
And like so many survivors of so
many genocides, they brought most
of their story to their graves.
We know bits and pieces.
We know that my grandmother
Haigouhi Sherinian,
her father provided cavalry horses
to the Ottoman army
and had for years.
In 1915, rather than
acquire the horses legally,
they shot him to death,
confiscated the herd.
Confiscated the horse farm.
And for good measure,
confiscated the Sherinian home.
My grandfather, Levon, he
had three older brothers.
And at the start of
the Armenian genocide
in 1915, they were all alive.
They were in Cairo.
They had made it.
And yet, somehow, between
1915 and 1927,
when my grandparents
immigrated to the United States,
all three brothers were lost
to the myths of history.
We know nothing about
what happened to them.
We nothing of why they vanished.
This little family you
see in this photograph,
which would soon increase by
two more, my uncle and my aunt.
In some ways, represents an almost
classic immigrant American story.
And the tug of war between American
assimilation and cultural retention.
That home in Tuckahoe,
New York, where Levon
and Haigouhi built their
family, was an Armenian house.
Whenever I would visit
it growing up,
I would see it as an Armenian house.
Beautiful, plush, oriental
carpets everywhere.
My grandmothers intricate beautiful,
ornate Armenian lacework,
everywhere.
Floor to ceiling book cases
filled with books in a language
and an alphabet, I
couldn't begin to decipher.
This is actually one of my
rugs, not one of their rugs.
But I share this with those
of you in the community
who do not read or speak Armenian.
So, you can get a sense of
the beauty of the alphabet.
But in that Armenian household,
it wasn't just the books
that were Armenian, even
the vinyl was Armenian.
A Russian, Armenian pressing
of Komitas, circa 1968.
When the Bohjalian's
would go on vacation,
they would be part the
Armenian community in places
like Tannersville, New
York, in the Catskills.
In this summer photograph
of an Armenian [inaudible],
the Armenian party, the
Armenian gathering, you can find,
among the assembled, my
grandmother, my father and my uncle.
Behind the brick walls of that
Armenian house in Tuckahoe,
New York, everyone spoke Armenian.
When my father started
kindergarten at the age of five,
he couldn't speak a word of English.
Couldn't even ask where
the boys room was.
And so, like so many sons
and daughters of immigrants,
he chose to reinvent himself to be
as American as he possible could.
In the 1950's, he became
that most iconic
of mid-20th century American
business professionals in admin.
A mad man, think Don Draper.
That is how extensive
his reinvention was.
And yet, his parents Levon and
Haigouhi, as Armenian as they were,
even they were not exempt from the
relentless riptide of assimilation.
The one photograph we
have of my grandfather,
in which he is not wearing a suit,
is this one [brief laughter].
His first visit to Coney Island.
And of course, he's decked
out as an American cowboy.
When I was going through
some of my father's papers,
after my father passed
away, I found a document.
My grandfather, Levon,
was a jeweler.
He had two stores.
He had one on Maiden
Lane, near Wall Street.
And he had one in Tuckahoe.
When he got his American
certification as a watchmaker,
I noticed that he was
no longer Levon.
He was the more Americanized Leo.
Leo Bohjalian.
And yet, despite my
father's assimilation,
I would always be surprised
when I would come
across photographs,
such as this one.
This was a photograph of my father,
taken in all likelihood
on his honeymoon.
Yes, he's clearly trying
to stay out of the sun.
But there's more to
this picture than that.
Is it simply a very lighthearted,
I am channeling my inner
Lawrence of Arabia?
Or is there something
darker beneath the surface?
Something all too reminiscent
of what it must have been
like under the searing,
Syrian sun in 1915.
He married outside of the community.
He married an odar.
He married blonde, blue-eyed
Annalee Carolyn Nelson.
But if he was going to marry
outside of the community,
he married the perfect odar.
He married the perfect
Armenian by choice.
Annalee Carolyn Nelson,
came from a broken home.
A devastatingly shattered home.
A home that began with divorce,
so nasty that not only did her own
father not come to her wedding,
but she and her older
brother, my uncle Warren,
completely separated themselves
from the Swedish half of my family.
And so, Annalee Carolyn
Nelson, was not merely Levon
and Haigouhi's daughter in law, she
became, in essence, their daughter.
Welcoming her into the family.
This is a photograph of
my older brother and me.
I'm the baby, looking
slightly bewildered
by the photographic process.
How Armenian, by choice,
was Annalee Carolyn Nelson?
Well, she died years and years ago.
But my father died more recently.
As a matter of fact,
he died the summer,
before "The Sandcastle
Girls," was published.
When I was going through
all of the items that were
of totemic importance to my father.
The things that he cherished, up
until the moment he too passed.
I came across my mother's key ring.
My mother was spectacularly
superstitious.
She wouldn't leave the house,
much less got on an airplane,
without her keychain.
And among the items always on that
keychain, always on her person,
was a keychain with three items.
The Saint Jude medal, a Saint
Christopher medal and a bronze charm
of the nation state of
Armenia the Republic.
My mother was the one,
when I was growing up,
who made sure that I
read William Saroyan.
This is in fact my childhood
paperback of "My Name is Aram."
I still own this book.
It is still my dogeared pages.
My underlining.
It was my mother who
insisted, as a teenager,
that I read "Passage to Ararat."
And again, this is my copy
that my mother gave me.
And it was my mother who
first insisted that I read
"The Forty Days of Musa Dagh."
This is not that addition
I read as a teenager.
The edition I read as a
teenager, was an old book
of the month club addition she had.
Which alas, I no longer have.
But this is an equally
meaningful addition.
It's a first edition in English,
that my wife found me
one year for Christmas.
And it was my mother on Sunday
nights at 8:00, [brief laughter]
who would remind me
that Cher was Armenian.
It was my mother who first told
me that Mike Connors, "Mannix,"
was actually Krekor Ohanian.
When I was a young
advertising executive
in New York City, the stars aligned.
And one of the strange
gifts from the heavens is
that the account I worked on
as a young man, was Clorets,
the breath deodorant whose celebrity
spokesperson in the 1980's,
was none other than
Mike Connors, "Mannix."
And it was my mother who
first pointed out to me
that the director Ruben
Mamoulian was Armenian.
He had 31 cats at one point.
My friend Vi Babarian
[assumed spelling] tells me.
I've had as many as six.
Now, "The Sandcastle Girls," is
not the first time that I tried
to write a novel of
Armenian history.
The first time I explored
1915, was in 1992 and 1993.
I wrote the entire
manuscript, 392 pages.
And when I finished reading it,
I realized it was a train wreck.
Utterly unpublishable.
Nothing about this book worked.
Moreover, about this
time, Carol Edgarian,
published her remarkable
novel, "Rise the Euphrates."
And I remember thinking
to myself, why in the name
of heaven does anyone need
my take on this story?
When we have the work of
Carol Edgarian, Peter Balakian
and of course, Franz
Werfel's magisterial epic.
So, sent that novel to my alma
mater, where my papers are archived.
And you can go there and read it,
if you're a scholar or a masochist.
But I discourage you.
It's a bad book.
So, why did I try again?
Well, there are a number of reasons.
In 2008, for the first time in my
life, I wrote historical fiction,
"Skeletons at the Feast."
A novel about one German family's
complicity in the Holocaust.
And three young adults who
were trying to work their way
across the cauldron of Nazi
Germany in its death throws.
Hoping to stay ahead
of the Soviet army
and reach what they
believe will the safety
of the British and American lines.
Friends of mine, Armenian Americans,
sometimes said to me in 2008
and 2009, it would be lovely
if you would turn your
talents toward Anatolia.
And give voice to those echoes.
On February 2, 2010, this man
added his voice to that chorus.
He's my great friend,
Khatchig Mouradian.
He arrived here from Lebanon in
2007, to edit the Armenian Weekly.
I've known him since.
On February 2, 2010, we were
having a cup of coffee in Boston.
And he knew about the
manuscript from 1992 and 1993.
And he said, when are
you going to try again?
And when Khatchig says
when, he means it.
I had my marching orders.
And so, I decided that I would
try again to write that novel
of the Armenian genocide.
But one of the gifts
of waiting so long is
that I was older and more mature.
And I figured something out, while
writing "Skeletons at the Feast."
And it was this, when I wrote
"Skeletons at the Feast,"
I didn't need to educate my
American readers to the Holocaust.
All of my American readers knew and
understood what the Holocaust was.
Most of my North American
readers in 2010, however,
could not have found
Aleppo on a map.
Most of them knew nothing
of the Armenian genocide.
The irony, of course, is
that once upon a time,
all North American eyes were turned
in horror on the fraying edges
of the Ottoman Empire
and looking on aghast.
There had been bestselling
books in the United States,
"Armenian Massacres,"
"Bleeding Armenia."
Bestselling memoirs, such
as "Ravished Armenia."
The story of Aurora
Mardiganian, an Armenian girl
who survived the marches
into the desert,
immigrated to the United
States and published her story.
And wouldn't just be
a bestselling memoir.
It was a silent film, eight
reel, Hollywood blockbuster.
Today, but one reel exists, but
you can see that reel right here
in Washington at the
Holocaust Museum.
You can see it at Yerevan,
at the Genocide Museum.
And you can see it on YouTube.
And among the moments from Aurora's
memoir, that Hollywood recreated
in the American Southwest, was
the passage from her memoir.
When she looked on in horror as
women, on the march with her,
were stripped naked, nailed to
wooden crosses and crucified
under the searing, Syrian sun.
The New York Times
alone, ran 154 articles
about the genocide
as it was occurring.
Culminating in this front-page
story from July of 1919.
The conviction for what they
called crimes against humanity
or the architects of the genocide.
And this was America's first great
humanitarian outreach effort.
At the start of the first World War,
there were roughly two
million Armenians living
in the Ottoman Empire.
By the end of the first World War,
all but 500,000 would be dead.
But Near East relief, an
American originated organization.
Nickels, dimes, quarters at a time,
raised the money to save 125,000
of those women, those refugees,
those orphans in the orphanages
and scattered across the
deserts of the Middle East.
For the last eight months, I've
taken such pride in telling people
that I'm a grandson of
Middle Eastern refugees.
I'm a grandson of Middle
Eastern immigrants.
Today, there are roughly
61,000 Armenians in Turkey.
Almost every single one of
them living in Istanbul.
These are Ottoman census figures.
Once upon a time, everyone knew.
But the news cycles moved on.
It's not just 2017, when
the news cycles seem
to have an attention span somewhere
between cottage cheese and yogurt.
As Gore Vidal once said, "We are
the United States of amnesia."
There was the rise
of the Soviet Union.
The fledgling nation state
of Armenia was subsumed.
There's the Great Depression.
There was the rise of Nazi Germany.
And so, a mere 20 years after
that New York Times headline,
I showed you a moment ago, Adolf
Hitler famously said on August 22,
1939, before unleashing
his panzers on Poland,
"be merciless, be merciless.
After all, who today remembers the
annihilation of the Armenians?"
So, when I embarked on
"The Sandcastle Girls,"
I knew that it needed to have
an educational component that
"Skeletons at the Feast," did not.
And I began by creating
a female version of me.
An Armenian American
novelist at midlife,
who knows far too little
about her own ancestry.
As she says in the prologue to the
book, Laura Petrosian, she says,
"The world needs one of those black
and yellow books, Microsoft Word
for Dummies, "Piano for Dummies,"
the "Ukulele for Dummies,"
the Armenian genocide for dummies.
Something that could
educate Americans."
But I also knew this, no one
was going to read a novel
that was 1.5 million
dead in the desert.
And so, I thought of what I loved.
The books that I've loved.
The big, sweeping, epic love
stories set in the midst of war,
such as Michael Ondaatje's,
"The English Patient."
A love story set in North Africa
and Italy in the second World War.
And I'm showing you this movie
poster because I want you
to notice the biplane that
will be culturally important.
Books, such as Ian
McEwan's "Atonement."
A love story, set against
the backdrop of "Atonement."
And because I wasn't going to
write "The Sandcastle Girls"
for the Armenian community.
Because we know the story.
I was writing it for my readers
who didn't know the story.
I decided that the lovers, one
of them needed to be American.
The lovers, would be
Laura Petrosian,
the narrator's grandparents.
Her grandmother Elizabeth Endicott,
Mount Holyoke, class of 1915,
who ventures with a Boston based
friends of Armenia, to Aleppo.
And there, finds an innermost
ring of Dante's Inferno.
It's interesting to note that Mount
Holyoke had not one, but two English
and Armenian speaking
seminaries in Anatolia.
If you visit the Mount Holyoke
library in Hadley, Massachusetts,
there's a beautiful sculpture
of the Armenian alphabet.
A testimony to Western Massachusetts
long connection to Anatolia.
Who would Elizabeth
Endicott find in Aleppo?
Armen Petrosian, an
Armenian engineer from Von.
Who is in Aleppo, hoping
against hope
to find his beloved wife
Kartinai [assumed spelling]
and his infant daughter
Talin [assumed spelling].
Though, of course,
he fears the worst.
And so, the novel moves
back and forth in time.
Laura's rediscovery of who she
is as a person in the present
and Elizabeth and Armen's
story in 1915.
The book did well in
the United States.
But I want to share with
you the overseas covers.
Because they say something
interesting
about culturally how we
approach this material.
This is the United Kingdom cover.
I've christened it, "Downton
Abbey meets the English Patient"
[brief laughter].
I love it.
And I love the biplane.
There is no biplane in
"The Sandcastle Girls."
But because of the place that
the "English Patient" holds
in our culture, Simon and
Schuster, you made darn sure
that there's a biplane on the
cover of "The Sandcastle Girls."
The Norwegian edition,
"Sandcastles in Aleppo."
This edition breaks my heart.
Because the Aleppo you
see on the cover there,
exists now only in
romance and memory.
It's gone.
The Farsi edition, a
beautiful split screen image
that immediately conveys the notion
of our Armenia as a
diasporan nation.
We have the desert on one side.
We have New York City on the other.
The Polish edition, which
I've christened "The Game
of Thrones" [brief laughter].
The Latvian edition, which doesn't
deal directly with the text.
But anyone who has even a dollop of
Armenian blood inside him or her,
cannot help but be moved by this
breathtakingly beautiful image.
Most of the foreign
editions, however,
replicate the American cover.
Elizabeth Endicott, a woman
in white with a parasol,
looking out at the
Armenian Auschwitz.
The Syrian killing
fields of [inaudible].
The Armenian edition, the Russian
edition, the Brazilian edition,
aptly titled "Desert of Bones."
The Italian edition.
There's that biplane again.
The French edition.
Elizabeth is wearing
black in this one
because we know the French
will always sacrifice comfort
for fashion.
So, even though it is Syria in
July, she's no longer wearing white.
The Hebrew edition, with
that iconic parasol.
John Gardner, great teacher of
writing, short story writer,
a novelist, once said, there
are two ways to wake a reader
from the fictional dream.
Clumsiness, bad writing and
inauthenticity, bad research.
I have been guilty
of both in my career.
But for a book such as
"The Sandcastle Girls,"
research was critical.
Which is why so many times, over the
last few years, I've been traveling
to the Middle East to
Armenia, to Turkey.
And all of the photographs
I'm about to show you, I took,
except for this first one.
This first one was taken by
my wife, Victoria Blewer,
who is a fine art photographer.
And it's infinitely better than
anything else you're going to see.
But I want to share these
photos of Anatolia with you.
Among the echoes that reverberates
with me always, is Kayseri.
Because of course, that is
where the Bohjalian's are from.
Outside of Istanbul,
there are, I believe,
no more than four structurally
intact Armenian churches.
There is the tiny, beautiful little
church on Musa Dagh, for the 200
or so Armenians in that community.
All decedents of the survivors
of Musa Dagh, who returned.
But that is the only active
Armenian church congregation outside
of Istanbul.
That's one.
There's Akdamar, restored as
a museum of sorts on Lake Von.
There's [inaudible], restored
by the Kurdish municipality.
And there's this one on the screen,
Saint Gregory in Kayseri,
behind barbed wire.
On Akdamar, Saint Gregory
[inaudible],
there's no Armenian
congregation there every week.
But the structures remain.
And so, it was important to
go stand inside this church.
The Kurdish caretaker brought us
through the barbed
wire and let us in.
And as I was standing there
and whispering, moved,
my wife said to me,
you realize, don't you,
that this is where your
grandfather was baptized.
You're now breathing the
air that he breathed.
And whenever I see this image,
I hear not merely the echo
of my wife's voice, but I hear the
echo of that baptism in the 1890's.
Most Armenian churches
and monasteries
in Anatolia are not
structurally intact.
Most of them are relics.
They are places such as
[inaudible], also on Lake Von.
Once the home to our reverend
fathers, now the home to graffiti
and seagulls, [inaudible],
ransacked regularly for gold
that probably never was there.
This is the cradle, in some
ways, of Armenian civilization.
This is [inaudible].
This is what it looked
like circa 1910.
This is what remains today.
Saint Bartholomew on
the Iranian border.
I must have 75 images
like this on my phone.
I want to show you
just one more, though.
Saint Sarkis.
Whenever I show this image,
Armenians who have been to Ani,
which is in Northeastern
Turkey at the Armenian border,
most people presume it is Ani.
It's actually not, but
it is very near Ani.
Ani, the city of a thousand
churches in the Middle Ages.
But I share with you Saint Sarkis
because I took this
photograph in 2015.
If I had been standing on the
cliff, looking down at it in 1950,
you would have seen five
completely intact church structures,
all a part of this complex.
And today, this is all that remains.
Why? Because in the mid 1950's,
the five-church complex was used
for artillery target
practice, medieval churches.
Now, the Middle East and Anatolia,
are awash in unmarked masquerades.
Which I will share
with you, but one.
This is the Dudan crevasse.
And here's what the history
books said happened here
over a three-day period in 1915.
The 10,000 members of the
Armenian community were marched
to the edge of the cliff.
And every single one of them
was shot, stabbed or bayonetted.
Their bodies thrown
unceremoniously to the crevasse
at the bottom of the gorge.
The first time I went
here was in 2013.
And as I am always
when I go to Anatolia,
I was with my great
friend Khatchig Mouradian.
There are five other
Armenian Americans.
And the seven of us, after listening
to the echoes at the Dudan crevasse,
went to Chunkush to see the
remains of the Armenian church
and the Armenian monastery there.
And as we were leaving,
a Kurdish gentleman,
my age, knocked on or van door.
And begged us not to leave.
He said, please, you must
meet my mother-in-law.
She's 98 years old.
And we all did the
math in our heads.
His mother-in-law was born in 1915.
And so, we went to meet her.
And thank goodness, we did.
Because in this case, the
history books were wrong.
Not every Armenian was killed
that cataclysmic three-day period.
There's one young Armenian woman
in the line who was so beautiful.
That a member of the
Kurdish killing party,
pulled her from the
line and married her.
She had in her arms her
newborn baby, an infant.
And that is who we met
that day in 2013, Asiya,
the last living Armenian
in Chunkush.
And as Khatchig was getting
her story, with her hand,
she looked at us and she
said, you're Armenian.
You're Armenian.
You're really Armenian.
And that's when I got it.
Her son-in-law was a good
man, a very good man.
It wasn't that he wanted us to
meet her, he wanted her to meet us.
To see that while she is
the last living Armenian
in Chunkush, the race continues.
We survive.
Which is why when I return,
I always visit Chunkush.
And why, when I returned
there in 2014,
I brought my beautiful
daughter and my beautiful wife,
so that Asiya could
meet Grace Experience.
And see yet another generation
of Armenians walking the earth.
Now, I said I was going
to end with Nazaret.
In 2014, I came across
two-volume encyclopedia.
The notable Armenians of Kayseri.
And as I was thumbing through
this two-volume encyclopedia,
I came across my great
grandfather, Nazaret Bedros.
There were seven pages
about him in Armenian.
And I recognized him,
as will you, instantly.
And for the life of me, I could
not understand why there were seven
pages about a tailor.
So, I asked Khatchig, my
Guggenheim, my Godfather.
I said Khatchig, could you translate
this for me and explain to me?
And he called me up,
after reading it and said,
your grandfather wasn't a tailor.
Maybe he dabbled as a
tailor, but he was a writer.
He was, in fact, a prodigy.
At the age of 12, he was taken
from Kayseri to perform as far
as the Southeast as Jerusalem.
As far as the West
as Constantinople.
And he didn't just write
his poems, he sang them.
He was a troubadour.
He was performing across Anatolia
in the 1860's and the 1870's.
A Bruce Springsteen, of the
Anatolian plains [brief laughter].
And his poetry, it was upbeat.
It was ebullient.
It was an unceasing beautiful
celebration of the Armenians,
the Turks, the Kurds of Kayseri.
The landscape.
The topography.
Think Walt Whitman, with its
exuberance and enthusiasm
for the beauty and the
community of Anatolia.
All that changed at the end of
his life on November 18, 1895.
Almost a century to the
date, when his great,
great granddaughter Grace
Experience would be born.
In a runup to the Armenian genocide,
we call the Hamidian Massacres,
250,000 Armenians died, the
slaughter came to Kayseri.
And the Bohjalian family
was witness and victim.
And now, at the very
end of his life,
despite the fact among his children
was a little boy named Levon.
He wrote the longest
poem of his life.
A 70-quatrain epic, chronicling
what he witnessed on November 18.
I will share with you, but
two of the 70-quatrains.
"They killed infidels with axes,
daggers and didn't ask who you were,
whether merchant or coolie."
"They took the babies out of the
wombs of their mothers and those
who witnessed lost their minds."
Think [inaudible].
I have always been so proud
to be my father's son.
I was always so proud to be
my grandfather's grandson.
But that's the thing about
identity and about genocide.
Whenever we talk about genocide,
we always go right to the numbers.
The six million, the 1.5 million.
But it's not just the
souls that are lost.
It's the stories.
It's why the work of Levon Avdoyan
and everyone who works with him
in this wing of the Library
of Congress, are so important.
Because you collect the stories.
You preserve the maps.
You preserve the photographs,
the poetry, the Abovyan.
You preserve our cultural identity
against the relentless
tide of assimilation.
I find it so interesting that
as proud as I've always been
to be Aaron Bohjalian's son, Levon
Nazareth's grandson, that's in only
in midlife that I've
discovered how proud I can be
to be Nazaret Bedrose's
great-grandson.
Because it is only at
midlife that I've discovered,
I am not the first
Bohjalian to be a writer
and to plum this part of my history.
I am humbled to be but the second.
Thank you so much [speaking
in foreign language]
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.